احضروا وزير الخارجية المصري
شكري وهو وزير خارجية شكرا
جزيلا لوجودكم هنا حقا نقدر
ذلك بالأمس أه لأول مرة في فترة
ولايته قام الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
أنطونيو جيز بتفعيل المادة 99
التي كما تعلمون تطلب من مجلس الأمن الدولي
لإعلان وقف إطلاق النار في غزة
أم نشر على تويتر أه المعروف الآن بـ
x أقتبس النداء لوقف إطلاق النار أوه أنا
آسف رد وزير الخارجية الإسرائيلي
بالدعوة ووصف غوتيرز بأنه
خطر على السلام العالمي ونشر على
x أقتبس النداء  وقف إطلاق النار في غزة
يشكل دعماً لمنظمة كاماس
الإرهابية
وتأييداً لقتل المسنين واختطاف
الأطفال واغتصاب
النساء ويجب على كل من يدعم
السلام العالمي أن يدعم تحرير
غزة من حماس أم ما هو ردكم
جيداً بالتأكيد  الأمين العام
يستعين بالمادة 99 من حيث
مسؤوليته في تقييم
مجلس الأمن عن أي تهديد
للسلم والأمن الدوليين أه كل التقارير الواردة من
وكالات الأمم المتحدة تقول أن هناك
كارثة كارثة
ستحل بكارثة إنسانية من
حيث  من الأوضاع أه
السائدة حاليا في غزة أه المدنيون
يعانون بشدة من نقص
الغذاء والماء والرعاية الطبية والصرف الصحي
أه الرعاية الصحية أه
تماما أه كارثية لذلك أه هذه
مسألة يجب معالجتها من
منظور أخلاقي
يجب على الأمين العام أن يتحمل
مجلس الأمن وعلى مجلس الأمن أن يتحمل
مسؤولياته أه مصر
أعرفها لعبت دورا حاسما في
المساعدة على دخول المساعدات الحيوية
وكذلك السماح لبعض الناس بالخروج من غزة عبر رفح
المعبر الحدودي الوحيد الذي لا
تسيطر عليه أه إسرائيل  أم اليوم
نشرت السلطات المصرية قائمة
تضم 63 مواطنًا أمريكيًا ومواطنين أجانب آخرين
سمح لهم أخيرًا بالخروج من غزة لماذا استغرق الأمر
وقتًا طويلاً لإخراج الناس من غزة حسنًا، هذا
كله مرهون بالاتفاقيات التي
يمكننا إبرامها أه  وأه مع
حماس مع حماس مع إسرائيل
وبمساعدة أه السفير ديفيد
سافيلد لذلك الأمر متروك تمامًا أه
الإسرائيليين لتحديد وتقديم
قوائم أولئك الذين يمكنهم الخروج وعندما
يفعلون ذلك نقوم بتسهيل إعادتهم إلى وطنهم
لذلك هذا هو  كل ذلك من أجل الحفاظ على معبر سلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني
وعدم التأثير على الإطلاق على تدفق
المساعدات الإنسانية نحن نلتزم
بالترتيبات التي أه تم
الاتفاق عليها بمساعدة
السفير ساوثفيلد أعرف أن مصر
لا تريد أن تغادر أم غازين غزة و
و  الانتقال بشكل دائم إلى مصر أعلم
أنك لا تريد ذلك ولكن هناك من
يعتقد أن مصر يمكن أن تسمح لمزيد من
الأشخاص بالخروج إلى خطيئة
الانتقال مؤقتًا حتى
تنتهي إسرائيل من حملتها العسكرية وتسمح
لهم بالعودة إذا كانت إسرائيل والولايات المتحدة
الدول تضمن لهم
العودة عندما تنتهي العمليات العسكرية
لماذا لا يسمحون لهم بالهروب بشكل جيد
فهذا يشكل انتهاكا
للقانون الدولي الإنساني أي شكل
من أشكال النزوح سواء كان داخليا أو
خارجيا يعد انتهاكا ولن
نصبح
ضمنا أه طرفا في  مثل هذا
الانتهاك ولكن أه الفلسطينيين
أنفسهم لا يريدون المغادرة وبالتالي
لا ينبغي تهجيرهم قسراً
أه تصفية الفلسطيني
الناتج عن إخراج جميع الفلسطينيين من
أراضيهم أمر غير مقبول وكما
قلت هو انتهاك للقانون الدولي
الإنساني على الإطلاق  منذ أن
سيطرت حماس على غزة كانت
الانتخابات بالطبع في عام 2006 أم أن مصر
ساعدت أيضًا في فرض حصار على غزة
أم لأن حماس بالطبع هي
ثمرة للإخوان المسلمين أه
أي رئيس CC ليس معجبًا به أعتقد
أنه من العدل أن أقول  أم هل تظن أن غزة
ستكون أفضل حالا
والشعب الفلسطيني سيكون أفضل حالا إذا حكمتها
مجموعة مختلفة عن حماس حسنا في البداية
أنا أه لا أعتقد أنه من
الدقة القول إن مصر شاركت
في عزل أه غزة معبر رفح
يعمل باستمرار  كان مفتوح أه لإخراج
الناس لتلقي الرعاية الطبية أه
لكن لم تشارك في أي
حصار إطلاقا لا لم نشارك
في أي حصار
كان الفلسطينيون يخرجون أه
يطلبون التعليم في مصر الرعاية الطبية  في
مصر لم تمنعوا أي إمدادات من
دخول غزة إطلاقا سلاح الجو الملكي أصلا
معبر للناس وليس
معبر للسلع
المعابر الإسرائيلية هي أه
المسؤولة عن ذلك وهذا
واجب على أه الاحتلال
الذي  هي إسرائيل لتوفير أه احتياجات
الشعب الفلسطيني لذلك كان سلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني
مفتوحًا دائمًا ولم
يغلق أبدًا ويستمر أه في
دعم الشعب الفلسطيني وأه
في أي وقت كان مغلقًا جيدًا على أي
حال ما رأيك في
سيكون الشعب الفلسطيني في وضع أفضل
مع مجموعة أخرى غير حماس بالنظر إلى
شعور حكومة CC تجاه
جماعة الإخوان المسلمين وحماس هي فرع من
جماعة الإخوان المسلمين، هل تعتقد أنهم
سيكونون أفضل حالًا مع مجموعة،
مجموعة مختلفة، مجموعة كانت؟  أكثر
استعدادا للانخراط أه في
التعايش السلمي مع جيرانها كما
تفعل مصر أه من حماس حسنا
أعتقد أن هذا أه أمر
يقرره الشعب الفلسطيني وأه لقد
اعترفنا دائما بالسلطة الفلسطينية
باعتبارها
السلطة الحاكمة المختصة لكل من  الضفة وغزة
أه إخراجها من غزة كان إخراجا عنيفا
أه وإلى الآن
لم يتمكن من العودة أه لذلك أعتقد أنه من
الضروري أن يظهر الشعب الفلسطيني من أه
سيقبله
لحكم القطاع
السؤال الأخير و  يمكن أن يكون الأمر سريعًا لأنني
أعلم أنه ليس لديك تفاصيل للدخول فيها،
ولكن عندما ينتهي القتال،
ونأمل أن يكون ذلك قريبًا، هل ستكون مصر
مستعدة للعب دور في مساعدة
الشعب الفلسطيني على إعادة بناء غزة والحصول على
حق تقرير المصير بشكل جيد  قبل هذا
الصراع كنا أه ساهمنا بنصف
مليار دولار في إعادة إعمار
غزة هذه هي المواجهة السادسة
بين إسرائيل وأه حماس وما
تلاها أه من تدمير
البنية التحتية في غزة لذلك
سنكون دائما داعمين سنساهم دائما
في أه  إعادة الإعمار لتحقيق مصلحة
الشعب الفلسطيني في
غزة وزير الخارجية المصري شكري
شكرا جزيلا لوجودكم هنا وكما هو الحال
دائما نصلي من أجل السلام في المنطقة
شكرا لكم تماما